who are you you here at gunslinger right
[Music]
there are no coincidence not anymore
what are you most excited for fans to
see one into this movie existing fans of
the book I want them to see the
visualization of something that is
deeply entrenched into Stephens
psychosis and then it is literature and
the fact that we brought that alive I
will know it's time to see their and for
fans that don't know this I want them to
step into an original title view you
know original not a remake two
characters that come from very very
different opposing histories and then
how that's put together it's it's a fun
formas it's yeah it's got lots of
beautiful visual effects but it also has
real characters at now at the heart of
it real people stories
I saw someone on Twitter tweet out that
this films on their bucket list like in
life seeing this move in the bucket list
what roles were left for you guys on
your bucket list I can't say this for
the last ten years the last film I did
the last character I played is always
been my favorite
the deadline isn't that she had a no bro
I mean if I'm really honest I just
directed a film and I think directing
that's gonna be my you know my pinnacle
careers to be a director there's so much
playing characters but directing
characters I did not kill with my gun
[Music]
iq of my heart
you
you